now to Brazil where the government's
coming under fire for its decision to
change the way it reports coronavirus
Statistics with more than 36,000 deaths
Brazil now has the world's third highest
death toll and the second highest number
of cases behind the United States but
the country's Health Ministry says it
will now only report cases and deaths
over the last 24 hours
and will no longer give a figure for the
total number of deaths thousands of
people took to the streets of cities
across Brazil including South Paulo to
protest a for and against president
chair bolson ro and his handling of the
crisis he's been criticized for
downplaying the danger of the pandemic
and dismissing the need for protective
measures now South Africa's lockdown
despite being eased recently has hit the
poor particularly hard unemployment is
soaring and millions are out of work in
one part of Cape Town a former gang
leader has stepped in to help those in
need his efforts have met with thanks
and skepticism many Charities in Cape
Town feed the hungry what sets this one
apart is the fact that it's organized by
a former gang leader
Leon Meyer used to head the Mongols one
of the most feared gangs in this city I
know now most of the people don't have
financial wise and start some people
feed each other the slogan on his
t-shirt says the harder you fall a
stronger you rise it could describe
Meyers own life he was behind bars for
18 years for crimes including a murder
conviction this area the Cape Flats has
a reputation for organized crime and
drug trafficking Cape Town sees an
average of 8 murders every day but
lockdown has led to a drop in gang
warfare according to a local pastor he's
been trying to mediate between gangs for
20 years
I like to think about the quality of a
blessing in disguise but it is really it
has really brought people together from
all walks of life we have I have been in
the lavender area and symbol Giri when I
get to other gang leaders most of them
were busy preparing filled with huge
pots it's like the Robin Hood have a
story and all I'm saying where these
motives are sincere or not how do you
how do you explain that Turkey
there's a recent a mother of four says
Leon Meyer has become a symbol of hope
in the area since the lockdown she used
up her welfare payments halfway through
the month unemployment is rife here but
criminologist Don Pennock is convinced
gang members have an ulterior motive for
helping out their community gangs in my
experience so don't do anything for
anybody else they they they it's all
about themselves it's all about what
they can gain so you know my first
question would be if they're
distributing food parcels why you know
what are they getting out of it and you
know they might want to look good in
their communities but they might be
using that there's a lockdown so you
know how do you get out and distribute
your drugs back on the Cape Flats Leon
Meyer admits that breaking with the past
is easier said than done never gonna go
away I'm gonna be dead someday they know
that gangsters will always be here there
will always be gangsters he's the way we
stay around in the way we love they put
us all together
I used to considering yourself against
I'm against I'm a born again sir I'm a
monk look I will stay against them
that's the only way out for me and
through this I can supply my people
around
in the meantime Desiree Simon is heading
home with dinner she say she doesn't
judge others a priority is making sure
her children don't go to bed hungry
here's a look at some of today's
coronavirus developments the EU health
regulator is looking to fast-track the
approval of Gilead Sciences antiviral
drug REM des avea as a potential covered
19 treatment in Europe that's after the
u.s. drug maker are submitted its
marketing application New Zealanders
declared victory over coronavirus and
lifted all domestic restrictions on
Monday our border controls will remain
in place the country recorded just 22
deaths the UK's a two-week
self-isolation rule for most arrivals
has now come into force airlines have
launched legal proceedings over the
government against the government over
what they say is a disproportionate step
now adding his voice to those of the
airlines the chief executive of London's
Heathrow Airport has expressed his
concern that the UK economy will be
further held back by these new
quarantine rules the airport is normally
the busiest in Europe but has had to
close a three of its five terminals
because of the lockdown
long waits while travelling are nothing
new but industry bigwigs in the United
Kingdom are worried about a new travel
delay starting today travelers to the UK
must quarantine for 14 days after
arriving so far the rollout has
reportedly been bumpy so all the plane
was in the bus even though before we get
to the flight they say keep your social
these things keep your masks on and all
that stuff but the bus was is literally
30 centimetres between all of us
apparently people are not informed that
you need to
fulfill online form before you come here
I've seen maybe five persons by people
who came the restaurant didn't do it so
that will delay the time the government
says it's trying to protect Britons from
the next wave of coronavirus and is
ready to ludie steep fines of up to a
thousand pounds to enforce the
regulations detractors like the head of
Ryanair have called the rules useless
and unenforceable others worry it could
be the final nail in the coffin for the
country's hard-hit tourism industry
meanwhile the CEO of Heathrow Airport
said the measures will slow down the
country's economic recovery and until we
have an exit from this blanket
indefinite quarantine then we're not
gonna be able to get the UK economy up
and running the quarantine also extends
to rail services in the country's
motorways London says it will review the
measures at the end of the month New
Zealand has lifted all of its social
distancing measures after reporting no
active cases have covered 19 Prime
Minister Jacinta Arden told the country
they could go back to business as usual
from midnight Monday after becoming one
of the first countries in the world to
successfully eliminate the virus are
talking to reporters the Prime Minister
described her reaction when she learned
that the country was virus free I did a
little dance the rather job is not done
there is no denying this is a milestone
so can I finish with a very simple
thank-you
New Zealand well thank you Jacinda DW
reporter Rebecca Ritter's has been
looking into this story welcome Rebecca
so how have they done this well mainly
because they were very quick to act Phil
they were very quick and that quick and
they were very sort of strong in their
reaction initially New Zealand like most
other countries took the flatten the
curve approach trying to make sure that
there weren't too many cases to
overwhelm the medical the hospital
systems but very soon some modelling
came out showing that tens of thousands
of New Zealanders could in fact die of
Cova
so Jacinda Arden's government decided to
swiftly change that approach and she
moved towards the elimination method
they is precisely that to completely
eliminate the disease from the country
on March 23rd they announced a national
lock down one of the world's strictest
they shut the borders they asked
everyone to stay at home and they only
allowed essential services to operate
now at the time the country only I
shouldn't say only but they had a
hundred and two which cases which
compared to many other countries was
very few at that time to have such a
strict reaction now they are the only
country to eliminate it I must add
Montenegro here in Europe has reported
they have no active cases Fiji also and
the Faroe Islands but New Zealand is
definitely the first country with over a
thousand cases to have eliminated it so
will they be able to stay corona free
well it's a bit of a million-dollar
question I'm not a virologist obviously
but that will really depend on how the
next phases of the opening up go handled
really and while the country is
internally opening up a lot its
remaining largely closed to the rest of
the world borders will shape stays shut
people returning from New Zealand will
still have to quarantine for fourteen
days it's mandatory that's um in a hotel
and there's obviously some pressure
because economically in the countries
hurting from this so there is talk of
so-called travel corridors with
Australia which is also been quite
successful in eliminating the disease
obviously New Zealanders are overjoyed
about their success but Arden was was
also you know putting a word of caution
saying we've got to be prepared let's
have a little listen to what she had to
say we are confident we have eliminated
transmission of the virus in New Zealand
for now but elimination is not a point
in time it is a sustained effort we
almost certainly will see cases here
again and that is not a sign that we
have failed it is a reality of this
virus so how people are viewed the Prime
Minister's response Arden is one global
praised I mean well I'm Australians but
I want to be very familiar
with her as being from the neighboring
country but she's she's known throughout
the world she's got a huge following on
social media she's really popular not
just because of her response to covert
but domestically her ratings have gone
up during this crisis she's people
globally and domestically think that
she's done a really fantastic job that's
not just that's not to say she's without
critics of course obviously the
opposition are saying she let the
lockdown go on for too long I mean the
country heavily relies on tourism and
obviously they're going to be hurting
but you've come out to that to say that
I my budget will not be one of austerity
I I'm spending is the way to get through
what will be very hard times to come so
you know she's she's looking set to to
do very well in elections in September
Rebecca ruses thank you